on va lui donner ses notes ses mots aux
mains de mes petits protégés il le sait
jamais nommément et j'ai envie de le
faire voler c'est vrai maintenant un os
est vrai alors qu'il y aura peut-être
d'autres prennent d'ailleurs pour vous
magie joint entre janvier et juin a été
la petite bonne nouvelle
il avait fait ses maximes pays si tu
seras à tout jamais dans mon coeur et ma
part si tu pars sur une autre chaîne
maxime kenny dans tpm paix c'est avant
tout des déguisements qui le met bien en
valeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi mais ça des mois
mais le meilleur rôle de maxime reste
celui de bill avec un costume et un
humour plus vrai que nature faut
regarder
il ya mon copain casimir aux annonces et
bernard montiel maxime tennis est aussi
le spécialiste média de l'émission
toujours au courant des dernières infos
ça fait juste les audiences le doc / ne
sont pas communiqués ça fait un énorme
carton c'est arrivé sur tf1 il ya
combien de semaines de trois 3 semaines
déjà trois semaines doit commencer à
fonctionner le crois pas tu es une
audience si c'est pas la donner et pour
dénicher ces fameux scoop
maxime n'hésite pas à enquêter sur le
terrain même en zone dangereuse
comment on est reçu quand on vient de
touche pas à mon poste oui à la
conférence de presse devait être passés
dessus un bain en tout cas je me
présente pas comme chroniqueur à touche
pas à mon poste mais on vous reconnaît
connard bref maxime gainey un élève
appliqué investi et très bosseur alors
surtout continuer comme ça oui bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maxime karol et vincent vous pouvez
donner votre avis sur ce que vous avez
vu n'hésitez pas voilà alors on va
démarrer gentiment par raymond c'est
quoi ces allusions au salon dirait
jacques raymond nouveaux venus des
chauffeurs livreurs le matin ils
continuent à chauffer à livrer ça va
plus il chauffe un pouvait boucler c'est
avant tout mon pote très bon ça fait pas
mal donc on se connaît maintenant ça va
faire plus de 10 en 10 ans il est à la
radio avec moi car je me rappelle voilà
il était et on était comme ça quoi
c'était comme carole et moi mettez en
père noël dans le bois de boulogne
c'était bien non non monsieur je pense
que mon beau pays a rapporté plus
d'argent
[Rires]
ces quarts alors maxime guennoun maxime
du rejet bas appareil comme tout le
monde ça fait un mois j'ai rencontré là
ses points forts ibos parce que ça il
est calé sur ces sujets sur ces sujets
il est politiquement correct ou
hypocrite je sais pas c'est celle là
aussi c'est l'autre mais toujours
bienveillant il me parle il parle de ma
vie me demande ce que je fais le matin
ils s'intéressent il est souriant je
trouve super sympa franchement je trouve
sympa alors sympa suscitera métier oui
non mais c'est ça pour moi je trouve moi
je suis moi je vous dise que l'annoncé
j'ai pas fais maintenant avec lui je
suis vraiment le cas mais je suis
d'accord que toi moi il sur ce que je
vois moi il a l'air sympa et l'air
sincère il dit toujours vouloir c'est un
mec est capable de dire bonjour à un
porte manteau et les ailes et les peaux
et les points faibles je trouve sur des
mots d'avant-guerre je sais pas quel âge
talent mais à l'emporte-pièce ça se dit
plus assis parfois sont à 100 foireuses
et tu savone un peu comme de leurs maux
donc c'est pour ça que moi j'en sais je
me jean-michel excuse moi n'ont pas
passé raymond et pour ça je vais te
donner 6 5 et je vais donner des
encouragements aux médias de s'en tenir
[Applaudissements]
allez tu es sûr isabelle à aller où on
reste dans la baie de rio avec plaisir
alors je suis le prof principale alors
maxime vous êtes un doux qui joue au dur
alors c'est dommage parce qu'un agneau
6e mais une fois de plus nos peaux de
loups ça fera jamais un fauve quand même
que c'est con parce que la phrase
dépareillé et vous l'avez chier on peut
dire à l'autre rica lors des séries moi
j'avais un pote avait jugé tout le temps
j'ai rapporté tout le temps on fera
jamais d'un dauphin à rothau il est bien
d'accord c'est un as de la magie je
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée de
vous donner des primes sans la magie
mais sur tripoli
j'ai jamais vu un magicien se servir
aussi bout de sa baguette et surtout
quand même bienveillance sympathique
attachant en compagne anne bien les deux
vieux enfin le jeune vieux et la vieille
vieille et donc pour ça je vous mets un
très beau 8
[Applaudissements]
parce que pour qu'attaquer normalement
107 un journaliste médias et vous dites
il est très bon en magie mais vite je
vois pas mais bon c'est pas grave c'est
votre passé votre choix animé d'une
bonne un premier temps un magistère est
basée en syrie lors d'activités allez on
enchaîne après votre meilleur ami daniel
aller regarder lassé des jeux vous dire
qu'en 2000 sont comme ça là les deux sur
le même registre à ça c'est vrai qu'en
plus on s'est croisé quand même pas mal
de fois et depuis longtemps mais assez
un jour vous serez super copine suis
alors maxime et les points forts c'est
évidemment le côté totalement décalé moi
mon petit plaisir c'est de voir des
invités parfois qui ne qui ne vous
connaissent pas parce que tu as
mondialement connu et qui découvre comme
ça cette espèce de personnages ils font
une tête c'est génial donc ça c'est le
côté décalé ce côté look de jeune mais
avec un look de vieux vous êtes un peu
stéphane bern souza sim quoi donc moi
j'adore donc ça c'est le point fort est
le point faible c'est en fait ça
commence par un point fort vous êtes un
gros gros bosseur mais le travail il
faut pas que ça se voie trop attrape
existe une danseuse classique le travail
on le voit pas on oublie parfois vous
avez d'abord on voit un petit peu trop
vous avez travaillé donc il faut alléger
un petit peu ça mais je vous donne quand
même un beau 6 d'encouragement
oui alors moi je vais je vais commencer
maxime je trouve que vous avez un réel
style et ça c'est important un style
dans la manière dans la manière d'être
de présenter qui est vraiment propre à
vous ensuite je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord vraiment quand tu dis qu'il
utilise un peu des jargons d'ancien
français moi je dirais plus que tu as le
mot juste et on a une très belle langue
en france et donc c'est très très bien
d'utiliser le mot juste ça donne un peu
plus se voit ensuite je trouve que tu es
bienveillant et ça dans n'importe quel
métier journaliste eut pas très
important et ensuite le petit le petit
petit petit point négatif il faut passer
il faut pas perdre confiance
il faut pas se laisser déstabiliser mais
autrement très très bien je vais pas
donné l'excellence parce qu'il ya encore
de la progression sur possible donc je
donne ça que je vais te dire et les
téléspectateurs le savent un dvd
aujourd'hui en expérience d'êtres
humains c'est logique je suis
[Rires]
aujourd'hui je suis capable de voir
quand deux personnes sont capables à tes
yeux sheeran le chose et vous deux et je
sais que roger n'est pas là il ya quatre
ans et je vais vous dire tout ce qui se
passe sur ce plateau restera sur ce
plateau ça ne sortira pas de l'ensemble
de la france non mais vraiment non mais
est ce que vous auriez pu être attiré
par maxime haut niveau alors déjà
content
quel débat par un homme
ça on sait qu'ils imputent l'hyperbole
quand je suis arrivé j'ai su trouver
maxime très très beau et charmant
physiquement et c'est pour ça que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi actuellement n'a
pas encore de nana j'ai pas trop bien
contient aussi la bouche et au niveau au
niveau de l'intérieur c'est une très
très belle personne c'est une très belle
âme j'ai aussi découvert en laponie et
vraiment c'est un talent c'est moi de
préférer maintenant c'est la vérité non
mais c'est un vrai gentil c'est une
brève alors vous qui êtes vous qui
venait d'arriver dans l'équipe qui est
votre préférée maintenant en haut puis
la laponie qui vous allez trouver trop
gentil bah du coup vu que jean millet
pas là je peux dire que c'est maxime les
deux il ya eu un moment franchement vous
dira non que j'aie vu parce que moi je
tournais beaucoup la nuit pour voir un
petit peu ce tissage étape en veillant
et je peux vous dire j'ai vu des gens
sortir le champ repartir dans l'autre
sens enfin vous verrez tout ça en tout
cas sachez que ceux qui ont pécho ne
sont pas ceux que l'on croit
oui madame il faut quand même savoir que
maxime est ce que vous vous donnez
donnez votre vous avez donné votre
maintenant j'allais donner un petit
scoop
adacore faut quand même savoir que il a
invité delphine a dîné demain soir je ne
suis pas encore au courant n'a pas parlé
dans sa version vous espoir là pour
[ __ ] la merde on m appelle à la
merci at elle a vite assuré ben voilà il
va très bien et alors vous allez où
souvent on peut enfin parler
sérieusement connerie de [ __ ] et m'a
d'abord dire bernard montiel on laisse
les gentilles à bord alors moi je trouve
que c'est un personnage atypique et
c'est ça qui est intéressant chez lui il
a une vraie personnalité et il est
détonnant dans ce groupe à sa façon de
parler s'exprimer et de réagir
donc ça c'est intéressant ce que je peux
lui reprocher c'est que il faut qu'il
arrive à dominer son trac être moins
déstabilisés par qui que ce soit peut
être plus sûr de toi
- apprendre et ex parce que tout comme
tu les connais pas tu es meilleur que sa
soeur spontanément comme ça autrement tu
es vraiment un bon camarade et
bienveillant et c'est agréable d'être
avec toi merci bernard bat justement
merci merlin arriver a pris trop on va
demander maintenant tu es là une chute
et m'ont dit non à petit en bas je
demandais d'abord on va demander à
beinheim apprendra alors son ancienne
petite amie son épreuve
alors écoute tu es vraiment tout le
monde l'a dit c'est tout et tous tes
copains n'ont dit si tu es un de ceux
qui travaillent le plus autant te dire
que bah oui parce que c'est une notion
qui peuvent écouter non messieurs les
jurés qui veut dire un truc un de ceux
qui travaillent le plus je veux dire au
dessus de zéro il ya donc étonné que
personne ne travaille avec une demi
heure par jour où il bosse beaucoup
je le vois sur leurs concurrents quand
on arrive en loge il encore son
ordinateur sur ordinateur ils regardent
les sites pornos
allez vous
j'en ai vu qui soleil entre
saperlipopette aussi les faits cette
mascarade
qu'est ce que c'est que ce tohu bohu
léger jamais des goûts de prêt si on
fait attention fait peur sa part
complètement cacahuètes donc donc tu
bosses tu bosse énormément tu te donnes
à foulon l'émission tu as envie vraiment
de faire partie de l'aventuré donc tu te
donne tous les moyens pour faire partie
de cette aventure
c'est très bon camarade est extrêmement
gentil et c'est pas c'est pas un défaut
d'être très gentil passant parfois quand
on entend de l'embryon sous-entend que
c'est que tu es crétins c'est pas du
tout le cas tu es vraiment un vrai
gentil avec un vrai bon fond après
effectivement tu as un petit souci de
jeu suite est toujours un peu premier
degré donc tu prends tout premier degré
tu as du mal un peu hâte la chebba
typiquement là tu t'es levé tout de
suite en dix ans prenant un peu en
premier degré alors que c'est que de
l'humour bien évidemment quoique je sais
pas si tu regardes et puis si tu as
envie de regarder du porno ce ton
problème
voilà mon père tous et bonne raison je
te donne un joli cette allergie le
gardait c'est surréaliste pour le monde
gardait la liberté à l'isi moi je suis
vraiment impressionné pour une fois
pourquoi à ce que j'ai devant moi celui
que cyril que j'écoute énormément
considère comme l'animateur de demain
vrillé plutôt essayer d'être le
chroniqueur d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
d'après votre plus grand point fort sa
votre bonne humeur
vous êtes là social 22 malades dans
l'équipe mais c'est par avouer appel
moral
et puis vous devez faire du génie gay
n'y a pas ce que vous avez relégué aux
oubliettes votre grand rival thierry
moreau mais oui aujourd'hui au royaume
des taux car vous êtes le seul droit
gagnant après que le plus dur était
arrivé non mais vous avez plein de
points forts vous avez ma vue plein
plein plein vous avez une vie
sentimentale et bourriche quand j'ai
fait d'employer des mots que vous
utilisez kelly vous échappe
mais diantre que nenni c'est pas grave
vous rattraper avec des scoops à foison
des infos bidons à gogo formidable alors
cyril pour une fois j'ai pas trouvé un
seul point faible
ah oui et pour vous noté maxim j'ai
utilisé une méthode scientifique
j'ai mis un point pour chacune de vos
interventions pertinentes depuis vos
débuts dans touche pas mal et ça donne
une un autre formidable 10
je sais que c'est foireux mais j'ai fait
un tour de magie à l'agonie c'est juste
une illusion 0 il ya alors marc note
matthieu delormeau je veux dire que
matthieu delormeau aussi ici j'ai pas
votre meilleure amie de kanye
je sais que à mettre de la douceur mais
je sais non mais vous en plus on va on
dit la vérité
vous êtes très copine avec maxime c'est
sa copine avec voilà vous êtes mine de
rien de l'état meilleur et deux plus
proches c'est maxime etc et bien sûr moi
je pense que c'est quelqu'un d'hyper
sensible c'est ça qui lui fait des
fréquences et qui prend tous à coeur que
ce soit positif ou négatif
je crois qu'il se prend plein d'amour
après les déçus quand y en a moins c'est
son problème
après toujours le même problème c'est
que tu apprends trotter fiche je l'avais
même dit au conseil de l'année dernière
donc tu as encore des progrès à faire à
ce niveau là mais à part ça moi je te
soutiens à la vie à la mort et je t'aime
et 1,8
ouais allez cette petite trêve
cadets - deux de leurs bourses smie je
vais être un petit peu méchant mais
sincère alors et à mon avis je vais te
rendre service oui des gens on va
rappeler vous l'aimez bien mieux je n'ai
pas de là je juge avec honnêteté juste
juste avant quand vous que vous nous
parliez de nuit je sais que vous étiez à
côté de lui dans l'avion pour la laponie
oui comment ça c'est passé juste pour
nos téléspectateurs il a un talent assez
incroyable c'est celui qui a inventé la
machine à arrêter le temps quand il vous
parle c'est à ces personnes ont
développé un deux minutes simonson 7 et
4 en bronze
[Musique]
loretta qu'aux débuts dans la peau ni
quand même c'est vrai bas la prochaine
fois je me mets à côté de vous et vous
allez voir
essayez vous allez voir à la bni donc
voilà le tatp mpc la formule 1 des talk
shows et point d'entrée pmp faut soit
être drôle comme jean michel mr mordant
comme comme gilles moi je cultive et
comme géraldine beys elles ont beau
avoir une carrière comme benjamin
castaldi du charisme comme benaïm ou
tout ça à la fois comme moi du canada
l'actif et ça s'est retourné me suis
c'est moi le problème c'est que te
concernant maxime je n'ai pas encore
trouvé après un an et demi et à valeur
ajoutée en tous les cas dans l'émission
et c'est un souci
alors j'entends ouais il est gentil où
il est sympa franchement des gens qui
est sympa c'est formidable pour faire
éventuellement des les après miss france
2 ou france 3 en animateur mais dans
cette émission sur pc c'est un peu léger
anne sinclair disait on fait une
carrière ce qu'on te reproche toi le
problème c'est qu'on tende proches rien
bah t'es gentil était sympa donc c'est
un petit peu le souci mois gentil est
sympa en lisant des filles dans une
émission avec tous cette fiche parce que
ce qui est dans une fiche chez scapa là
pour moi ça fait pas un bon chroniqueur
donc je te le dis mais c'est gentil mais
c'est pourquoi pour le coup c'est
vraiment gentil méchant gens qui un
point sympa un point ça fait 2 sur 10
c'est pas pu trouver mieux
on est alors je vous le dis tout le
monde se dit la vérité ici et quand je
vous donnerai vos notes à tous on a
menti d'actes mans la vérité je vous
dirais exactement ce que je pense de
vous je pense qu'elle a qui devraient
pas venir d'ailleurs ce genre est notes
des twittos 7,9
l'un des chroniqueurs ses services 1,4
de malades et fait un excellent
trimestre bien vieux moussa et c'est
alors on peut voit pas et jean-michel il
a vu combien hier vous êtes devant
jean-michel tête comment jean michel
maire on note la gentillesse j'en ai
bavé mais calmez vous quittez le pays on
va pas non plus mais même si gentil
sympa ça fait ses camions bennes savez
ça merci papa calmez vous quand même